[Music]
the turkish army opened up with tank and
artillery fire on greek cypriot
positions near the nicosia airport
i'm on an island in the mediterranean
[Music]
and i'm at an airport
on the runway right now actually
[Music]
but this airport is completely empty
it's totally still there's no one here
[Music]
it's eerie it's empty it's falling apart
[Music]
the reason this airport is a ghost town
is because we are literally inside of a
border
[Music]
this is cypress
it is an island that's just under turkey
just to the left of lebanon and israel
so yeah i'm locked inside of a border
right now which i'll explain what i mean
by that in a little bit but the shorter
answer is that this is a gray zone it's
in no man's land and in fact challenges
what we even mean by the word country
this airport used to be a thriving hub
of international travel people
everywhere
and then that changed it changed because
of an invasion the turkish air attacks
came sporadically but swiftly the main
targets were greek cypriot police and
national guard buildings and above all
the airport where there was some heavy
fighting today
the greek cypriots sizeably outnumbered
by the turks were able to put up little
resistance
and not that long ago
we're talking like the 1970s it was that
conflict that locked this place into a
no-man's land into a conflict that still
continues to this day
[Music]
this airport is not the story here this
is just one piece of a huge puzzle
it's a puzzle and a situation that i
have been thinking about for years the
better part of a decade i've been
staring at this place thinking about it
looking at it and i'm finally here
i'm finally here to look at it in the
face to understand it to talk to the
people
to look at its story
and to try to piece together an
explanation of how this island was
divided not between two countries
but divided into four
the island where aphrodite the greek
goddess of love was born out of sea
spray cyprus is britain's base in the
middle east and the middle east is under
constant pressure in addition to clashes
with rebelling greek cypriots the
british are faced with keeping the peace
between the turkish greek protections
outnumbered by the turks were able to
put up little resistance
the greeks had no hope of victory
hate and fear
now rule cyprus
[Music]
i came to this island because i wanted
to understand something i've been
thinking about for years i studied it
back in grad school but never really
understood it
so after years of reading about this
conflict and looking at it on a map i
came
[Music]
i met up with some friends who were also
traveling in this region and who also
wanted to learn to expand their
perspectives on this poorly understood
conflict
[Music]
so you say the island is divided into
four but what are the four parts to
understand that you have to look at the
map
even though the country of cyprus is a
member of the eu and their flag
literally has an island on it it has the
entire island on it the republic of
cyprus actually looks like this
it only takes up 60 of the actual island
it's made up of mostly people who
identify as greek
so this is it this is the country of
cyprus only controls this portion of the
island it's just 60 of the island
wait okay so that's not the whole island
what is the remaining portion the
remaining 40
is complicated
first off you have a small fraction of
this island that is controlled by wait
for it
the british the british yes you guessed
it i saw that coming yes didn't we all
the british they mainly use it for
military purposes
and then you have this strip right here
that is owned by no country this is
controlled by the united nations it's a
buffer zone a cease-fire line set up in
the 60s and 70s to stop the fighting
[Music]
now the elephant in the room here which
is
the rest of this map
all of this up here is controlled by the
self-declared turkish republic of
northern cyprus according to the un and
to almost every other country this space
is not a country it's a self-declared
country that is occupying half of this
island almost but if you go to this
place it feels like a country it has
like a government that builds roads and
infrastructure and has political parties
and elections so it's
it so it is a country
kind of it's kind of a country how can
you be kind of a country
this land up here is occupied because
there was an invasion in the 70s
and at that time greeks and turks had to
separate they left their homes
completely empty thinking maybe they
would come back
but they never did as the turks advanced
the number of greek cypriot refugees
pouring into the dekhelia base is
growing rapidly there's this city in
what is now the occupied north that used
to be this like beautiful resort town
[Music]
when the invasion happened the people
fled
there was a bombing on this town and
they all fled and they thought okay once
the bombing's over we'll come back
and
they never did it's been 47 years and
they have not gone back they left their
homes they left food in their
refrigerators they left
their
pictures
their jewelry just
in their homes
i met a guy who left that day
he was 33 he took his two children and
they drove and after months of talking
to the turkish military
we got permission to go back with him to
visit his old home
and to talk about that experience
[Music]
wait
how could this city possibly go from
idyllic resort to the ghost town
basically
that's that is the question i've been
thinking about for a lot of years now
and to understand it
it really helps to go back
the first thing to know in the context
of this island is that everyone wanted
it always
this place is located so perfectly
in the mediterranean at the crossroads
of europe and the middle east and
northern africa that it is so perfectly
strategically located
everyone wanted
it was the persians and alexander the
great and then of course the romans show
up with their
jesus religion and do that thing you get
the point like cyprus was just a
strategic pond being conquered and ruled
by one empire after another for
literally thousands of years and that
gets us up to 500 years ago which is
closer to the root of today's conflict
when the empire from turkey the ottoman
empire came over they threw out the
current empire which is the venetians
and they came in they're like the
ottoman empire now rules cyprus
so i don't mean to interrupt because
like this is all fascinating but i have
always had the question of whether
turkey uh is named after the bird or if
it's the other way around this is just
something that's bugged me forever and i
figured i'd ask you
i mean we were talking about like the
conquering of this land but we can talk
about turkeys for a little bit
so the answer to that
is turkey the the bird is definitely
named after turkey the empire okay the
way that it works is that turkic people
used to bring this bird into europe and
sell it and they would buy it they would
call it a turkey fowl oh there's like
this turkey fell it's this bird coming
from turkey when europeans arrived to
north america and they saw what we call
turkeys today they're like oh that looks
just like the turkey fowl from like back
in europe the turks used to bring over
oh wow let's call it a turkey even
though it's a totally different animal
than the than the thing the turks were
bringing over and that's how we got
turkeys so the thing you eat for
thanksgiving or whatever is like is like
named after turkey yeah so i'm not not
that dumb of a question okay do you feel
satisfied with your turkey answer
because we can move on about the point
of the video which is about like how the
island was divided into four or do you
want to keep talking about turkeys
because i could talk about turkeys like
all day no i think it's okay
thanks for taking yeah time
okay so we're at the point where the
ottoman empire the turkey empire owns
cyprus okay and this is where turkic
people
arrive to this island and they find
mostly greek people
greek christians turkic muslims
different cultures and yet over the
years they made a harmonious society
together where they lived next to each
other in the same villages and towns in
peace
[Music]
let's get to modern day because it's
like the late 1800s
ottoman empire is crumbling like super
crumbling and who is the new kid on the
block that is not crumbling but is
rising the british
[Music]
so it's not that surprising to me that
the next part of the story is the
british
coming into a part of this but why would
they want
this specific island there was
particularly this one little strip of
water that made all the difference the
suez canal
was this new man-made canal that cut the
time from britain to india like
in half like it was so much easier to
get to india one of their major colonies
and britain was like we need to control
that and oh cyprus is right there next
to the suez canal like
it's a perfect lily pad for us to have
but the great importance of cyprus can
be seen from the map important little
island in the mediterranean it has
become a strategic center in the middle
east zone of this world war
so this is the big turning point in the
story the british own cyprus it is one
of their colonies and they're doing what
the british do well which is like
they're making maps they're doing
demographics and they're like oh you are
turkish muslims and you are
uh greek christians and they're like
separating people by like identity just
sort of on paper the people who've been
living here for thousands of years and
being conquered by every empire you can
imagine finally start to get fed up with
all of this
one british army truck is bombed killing
two soldiers and wounding 12. by the
1950s cypriots were done with british
rule and they had risen up in violent
attacks against the british the british
realized it was time to go home and it
looked like cypriots for the first time
would actually be able to govern
themselves instead of being tossed
around by outside powers
but the greek cypriots didn't want
independence they actually wanted to
join greece this was a political
movement called enosis
meanwhile the turkish cypriots didn't
want to be a part of greece they didn't
want to become even more of a minority
they instead wanted to divide the island
into two new independent countries one
for greek cypriots and one for turkish
cypriots this is what a power vacuum
will do to people when the fate of who's
going gonna be in control is up for grab
people latch on to their groups and
inflate their identities to divide
themselves from the other side these
were no longer just cypriots like they
had been for centuries now they had to
choose a team team turkey or team greece
and so this is the climax this is
actually where
the conflict becomes a big deal 1955 saw
sir john harding as governor and
commander-in-chief attempting to
reconcile greek and turkish viewpoints
all british proposals however were
rejected and a long period of riots and
outrages followed the british realized
that these divisions between turks and
greeks on the island that they had
helped create were now getting out of
control so they pull the page out of
their old playbook and a new british
plan described as an adventure in
partnership the plan was a classic one
to gather in london for a few days with
a few leaders and outside powers and
decide for the cypriots how their
country was going to be run
and that's what they did they all sat in
a room and they wrote a constitution for
cyprus and greece
and turkey were like both in the room
and they were like we know that you sort
of want to like join greece maybe or
maybe you want to have your own country
you're going to get neither of those
you're going to be an independent
country
and we're going to create this really
clever constitution where the president
has to be
greek but the vice president has to be
turkish and there has to be like a
certain number of greeks and turks and
like they created this like really
clever constitution that was gonna like
make everyone happy in theory and then
they're like you're gonna be independent
but we the british get to stay here with
our bases and greece and turkey
get to kind of have power still like if
something goes awry like they can swoop
in if they really need to that was like
a caveat to this this agreement that
they made in london
and in 1960 it happened
midnight in nicosia and sir hugh foote
entering parliament is followed by
archbishop macarios who is to take over
as first president of cyprus so
representatives of the two cypriot
communities and of greece turkey and
britain begin the signing ceremony
there are many documents to be signed
do any of us think that the british
crafting a constitution that's like
cleverly put together to make everyone
get along it's really going to work no
right
that sounds extremely flimsy it's very
flimsy telling other people how they
should structure their country is never
really works and it's like we've seen
that like quite a few times like is
anyone gonna
learn that unsurprisingly the whole
we wrote you a constitution that says
you should all get along thing didn't
work out and tensions between greeks and
turks started to heat up
for some time hatred between the greek
and turkish elements have been building
up
under such conditions it takes more than
a treaty to preserve the peace at this
amazing map i mean actually you should
see this
remember that i mentioned that like
greeks and turks sort of live together
as this constitution isn't working out
violence against turks who were always
the minority led them to leave their
home and they start to
gather into these little enclaves around
the country the turkish cypriots were
declaring that it would be impossible
ever again to live in harmony with their
greek compatriots and so the map went
from looking like this to looking like
this
but the strategic island continues to be
the scene of daily violence and
bloodshed
over in greece the new military
government saw this happening and
thought that this would be a moment to
swoop in and take over the government of
cyprus and try to realize this dream of
cyprus being united with greece and
that's when turkey's like greece you
violated the agreement we weren't
supposed to swoop in
on the island and unless there was
something really wrong
and so we're gonna swoop in because we
technically on paper say that we can
come in and restore the peace well they
did a lot more than restore the peace
turkey swoops in
and starts taking over the north
in a full-blown invasion with bombs and
tanks and military
like troops like hitting the like
beaches with guns like a full-blown
invasion and they start just taking over
the north of the island
and the people start fleeing the greeks
who realize that turkey's actually
invading
and turkey feels justified because they
feel like greece did it first
and so they just keep
from the battle going
high over the capital city the greek
cypriots decisively outnumbered by the
turks were able to put up little
resistance i've been glued to these
early reports of the invasion of the
island of cyprus by turkey there's this
one journalist from the uk named
jonathan dimbleby who was like one of
the first on the ground when all of this
was happening and he captures the
feelings of the people who had to flee
their homes to their side of the line we
didn't take anything with us in these
reports you start to hear two totally
different narratives and these will go
on to be the roots of the modern day
conflict on the island of cyprus the
first narrative is the greek narrative
from their perspective this is an
invasion to their country a theft of
their property turkey was invading their
sovereign territory and forcing them to
leave land that was rightfully theirs it
is unlikely that the turks will allow
them back there is no promise that they
will be compensated for their
confiscated homes and businesses
it is as if the greek cypriot world has
come to an end
we prepared to be dead than to live
under the turkish authority
but for turkish cypriots this was not an
invasion this was salvation turkish
cypriots had suffered immense violence
and brutality as minorities on the
island at the hand of their greek
compatriots and now turkey was swooping
in to save them to protect them that's
why turkish cypriots call this the peace
operation when i saw the tongues i
forget my unhappiness i was very happy
because
my
my life was safe my children's life was
safe and my my people i mean the turks
was all safe
i'm very happy of course people the
turkish population feel uh
more
safe
secure
because the turkish army is there to
protect them after three days of an
unstoppable offensive the turkish army
seems to have grabbed just about all the
land that wants on cyprus at least in
the northern and northeastern parts of
the island
[Music]
and then the turks in the north
declared a new country they were like we
are now the
turkish republic of northern cyprus a
new country it's effectively just turkey
by another name
[Music]
to stop the fighting the un carved out
these twin lines that cut right through
the capital of nicosia they stretch
across the whole island a buffer zone to
stop the violence
[Music]
and this establishes the lines we know
today with the republic of cyprus
controlling all of this the
self-declared turkish republic of
northern cyprus up here then of course
the british with the land that they held
on to when cyprus became independent and
then this u.n buffer zone which locks
within its boundaries the airport along
with people's homes businesses and farms
[Music]
this is an island divided into four
in one way only are greek and turk alike
they both now belong to a nation of
refugees
one of the reasons i came here was
because i wanted to see what this looks
like after years of looking at it on a
map what does it feel like for the
people to pick up and leave and flee to
their side of this new boundary
abandoning their lives and communities
we're about to go into
northern cyprus for the first time here
we go
as you drive through the occupied north
you see a lot of churches like this
i'm in a village where greek cypriots
used to live
but in 1974 they fled south leaving this
village empty
the turkish cypriots who were in the
south fled north and arrived to this
village to find empty homes and this
christian church
[Music]
and they converted it into a mosque so
that they could continue their religious
practices but eventually they built
a new mosque right next door
and they left this church totally
abandoned
where it lays today falling apart
[Music]
both sides suffered immense losses and
now empty buildings
are the most visceral solid symbol of
that loss
[Music]
these abandoned churches are peppered
all throughout the occupied north
[Music]
but perhaps the most haunting symbol of
this switching of sides happened here in
that thriving greek tourist town called
famagusta fam augusta was the tourist
resort of the island the major port much
of the wealth of greek cyprus was based
here last weekend the greeks fled in
panic before the turkish tanks they have
abandoned all that they have and they
won't return
now the town is deserted
we're about to go in i've been thinking
about this place for
the better part of a decade
and we're about to go in
the reason i spent months trying to get
access to film in this ghost town wasn't
just to capture it but rather to
understand the human tragedy that
happened here so i asked this man to
come with me his name is mr takis he's a
greek cypriot who was my age back in
1974. he lived here in famagusta he
owned hotels he was in the tourism
industry
but when turkey invaded he did what
everyone else did in this town he left
with his family and today he's returning
for the first time ever
easy to bear yeah
it brings out anger it brings out
confusion it brings out
disappointment my wife refused to come
yeah i came with my daughters today i
came with everybody
they
tell me don't talk yeah i lost my
i cannot connect
can you paint a picture to me on what
famagusta
was like the economy was so strong here
and
not only not only economically
johnny
but
culturally educationally it was a
wonderful period
i asked mr takis if he would be
comfortable showing me his old home
so we started walking through what used
to be his entire world the cafe he used
to come to often
his brother's old house where he went to
school i spent some of my best years
here
wow the school is now boarded up and
covered with turkish and trnc flags
to see this in this situation
makes me very very certain
as we walked through this ghost town i
kept trying to get mr takis to go back
to the famagusta of before the invasion
and to point out the places that he had
good memories from what do you remember
about that time but after a while he
finally just stopped me
johnny
i told you before i cannot connect i
cannot
you are asking about my memories yeah
they don't bring out
the full memories i want to describe
because
there is a reservation this is not the
town i lived this is not the town that i
was proud of yeah this is not the town
that has a tremendous history and
success
it
[Music]
is unbelievable
on that day that everyone had to flee
you thought you'd be coming back yes for
sure
everybody who left thought that they are
going away for two three days they
didn't take anything more than clothing
food
we walked through this city deep in
conversation and then mr takas friend
who was with us
signaled that we were getting close to
the house the one he hadn't seen since
he fled all those years ago mr takis
didn't pick up that we were getting so
close and when he looked up he realized
we were here
tell me about this building
shall i say
i could tell he felt caught off guard
and i began to regret having set this
whole thing up
well you didn't prepare me
i was subjecting this man to a traumatic
reopening of his old wounds also i could
make my video about the conflict it
started to not feel right but he assured
me that we could keep going and that he
wanted to do this no i want to go on the
outside
go from
he didn't want me to see his home from
this angle from this bombed out street
instead he wanted to see it from the
other side from the beach the part of
this town that still has some semblance
of its former glory not from here from
it looks like there's an entrance over
here maybe
now you will get
an idea why it was so popular i think
yeah i haven't seen the beach yet
[Music]
this is famous
from augusta
as we walked towards his house now from
the beach side it was clear that mr
takes still felt deep pride for this
place this beach this city in certain
areas there is even two quest uh water
it's stunning it's beautiful
and though his city and his property and
his stories are now a ghost town
occupied by an invading power when
you're on this beach you don't feel it
as much as like this yeah there are not
many in the world
[Music]
and then after a moment walking along
this beach we finally approached his
home
this is the first time you're seeing
this first time i see it after four to
seven years
it hurts me it's uh i cannot connect in
the sense that
it
what i see
doesn't bring you out all those
nice memories and the good time you had
yeah
you have to close your eyes and then it
all comes back
was the tourist resort of the island
all this belonged to the greeks
[Music]
it
is the turkish will allow them back you
didn't prepare me
my wife still
[Music]
refuses to come yeah
because it's painful
i'm coming here to do what like now we
see it and i cannot
go into it
what is the purpose
i'm not a tourist it's my home yeah in
my town
and i come here and you can go here you
cannot go there
you can see your house from distance
[Music]
it's a torture
it's a torture
i know it's difficult for everybody to
get into somebody's shoes but i'm sure
you appreciate cares a lot that's a lot
that's a lot
it's not right
i watched mr takis take a photo with his
daughters who he had brought to see the
house they almost grew up in
they stood in front of the turkish
military border that bars them from
actually going inside
and in that moment i felt a profound
sadness for it all
unlike anything i'd felt in the years of
studying this conflict
those conversations are so important
because like this isn't just a
international relations issue this is
like a human issue this is like people
and their identity and their homes
being lost because of great power
conflicts to me it's much more important
to have those types of conversations
than just to be zoomed out looking at a
map
[Music]
both greek and turkish cypriots suffered
immense violence and loss of their homes
and communities in 1974 and the years
leading up to it and throughout this
series i want to shed light not just on
this history but what it feels like to
live in this place today a country
divided into four full of buffer zones
and barriers and division
at the end of the day this is a division
that was constructed by outside powers
which is the story of cyprus the story
of a strategically placed island that
everyone wanted and was ripped apart
purely because of where it was located
[Music]
okay
well you made it through episode one of
uncharted this pilot series of something
that i want to do a lot more of there
are three more episodes so this is just
the beginning
um
this is a new form of journalism that i
am pushing
and i'm really grateful to the sponsor
who supported it which is commenter
cometier is kind of blowing my mind they
are a completely different version of
coffee than anything i've ever
experienced the way it works is that
cometier
works with some of the best artisanal
roasteries around the world
and they make beautiful wonderful coffee
they brew it themselves but then they
immediately flash freeze it like they
freeze it in these insanely low
temperatures to like seal in the
freshness and the aromas and the flavors
of this roasted coffee and then they put
it in these little metal capsules and
and send them to your house frozen
they show up you pull them out of these
capsules you put them into a cup with
hot water and you have delicious coffee
that is like the coffee that was brewed
i mean it's brilliant and it tastes
really good
[Music]
listen i'm a big coffee guy and i like
to think that i have like the art of the
pour over down with like my scale and
like my timer and all this stuff
honestly it takes a long time which is
fine on a weekend but like during the
week like
i sort of want a more convenient option
i could pay
for a coffee shop to make it and have it
delivered to my house which costs me a
lot of money or i could pay
way less and have a really good cup of
coffee that is reliable and sustainably
packaged and all this stuff through
commentary cometier is kind of a new
thing they're not fully open to the
public yet there's some wait list
if you want to bypass that wait list
there is a link in my description it is
commenter.com johnny harris that allows
you to bypass the waitlist and get fifty
percent off your first purchase which
makes this like one dollar per cup
which is insanely cheap for the quality
of coffee you're getting so if this is
interesting to you go to the link in my
description clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gives
you that 50 off and allows you to bypass
the wait list i feel really excited that
i discovered this and will be using it
for the foreseeable future so thank you
comment here for sponsoring this video
and thank you all for being here there
are three more episodes of uncharted
coming to you in the next few weeks
so keep an eye out for those see you
later
[Music]